[Musique]
trois journalistes espagnols et deux
journalistes français ont été arrêtés
hier à caracas
on est sans nouvelles d'eux l'espagne a
exigé publiquement la libération
immédiate de ces journalistes alors je
voudrais vous poser deux questions de ce
premier ministre premièrement la france
et l'union européenne vont elles
reconnaître le président gaillot avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard et que la guerre
civile n'éclate au venezuela
deuxièmement le gouvernement compte-t-il
exigé publiquement la libération
immédiate des journalistes français et
avez-vous de leur nouvelle je vous
remercie
je me permets de vous indiquer monsieur
le président malhuret que le ministre
des affaires étrangères et l'ensemble du
gouvernement a exigé la libération
immédiate de ces journalistes et de
leurs collègues et confrères espagnols
nous parlons aujourd'hui au venezuela
d'un président qui revendique un second
mandat présidentiel sur la base
d'élections qui se sont tenues en mai
2018 qui ne répondait de toute évidence
à aucune des conditions essentielles de
la démocratie aujourd'hui le venezuela
est à la croisée des chemins
depuis que le 23 janvier se sont tenues
des manifestations massives et que le
jour même le président de l'assemblée
nationale
wang wei d'eau a prêté serment comme
président par intérim du venezuela en
vue at-il affirmé
d'organiser des élections véritablement
démocratiques
notre responsabilité celle de la france
celle de l'union européenne c'est de
veiller au respect de la volonté du
peuple vénézuélien
c'est le sens de la déclaration du
président de la république qui le 26
janvier dernier a appelé à l' annonce
dans un délai de huit jours de la
convocation de nouvelles élections
à défaut monsieur le président nous
reconnaîtrons en pleine coordination
avec nos partenaires européens avec
l'allemagne avec l'espagne avec le
royaume uni croit ngaido comme président
par intérim du venezuela pour avancer en
ce sens
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de ces
individus dangereux capturés en syrie
sont détenus par les forces kurdes
le désengagement américain du levant
pose la question du devenir de ces
prisonniers qui pourrait revenir en
france
dès lors comment le gouvernement tente
il protéger efficacement les français de
ces criminels de ses ennemis de la
république
et alors que la menace terroriste reste
très élevé dans notre pays
ceux qui sont détenus aujourd'hui sont
détenus par les kurdes
si ces personnes sont expulsés de syrie
et si elle venait à être en contact avec
les autorités françaises elles seraient
autant d'émoi bien immédiatement arrêté
soumis à la justice
et je l'espère je le crois puni et punis
sévèrement
notre objectif encore une fois c'est
l'intérêt objectif de la france c'est
qu' il n'y ait pas de dispersion de ces
terroristes
nous parlons ici de crimes de guerre de
crimes contre l'humanité et de génocide
je crois que votre volte face n'est que
le marqueur d'une certaine faiblesse de
la politique étrangère au levant ils ne
doivent pas revenir
[Musique]